[Musik]
deutschland hat sehr viel zu diskutieren
boris becker im gefängnis der papst
vorwürfe gegen die nato und heute die
antwort auf andy schwarzers brief jetzt
fordern prominente intellektuelle die
ukraine schneller mit schweren waffen zu
unterstützen zu gast heute abend bei mir
claus strunz mit kritischen gedanken zum
papst und seine geplante reise nach
moskau reif ist der initiator des
offenen briefes an scholz und alice
schwarzer wir werden es den
csu-politiker ein petzschner molinari
der sich sorgen um die extreme
preissteigerungen macht und eine
aussetzung der rundfunkgebühren fordert
alexander von schönburg der den
hämischen umgang mit tennis star boris
becker kritisiert außerdem diskutieren
wir auch noch über die einrichtungs
bezogenen pflicht lassen sie uns direkt
starten mit herr fücks mit dem
tagesaktuellen thema sie haben einen
offenen brief an herrn scholz
geschrieben dann haben sie auch direkt
unterstützer gefunden wohin geht es in
ihrem betrieb
um eine klare position für eine
entschiedene eine energische
unterstützung der ukraine in ihrem
abwehrkampf gegen den russischen krieg
gegen den russischen überfall und das
heißt lieferung auch schwerer waffen die
unterscheidung zwischen defensiv und
offensiv waffen macht gar keinen sinn in
einem verteidigungskrieg sind alle
waffen defensive waffen das heißt auch
eine klare europäische
beitrittsperspektive für die ukraine ich
mein kein land hat einen höheren preis
bezahlt um mitglied des demokratischen
des freien europa zu werden und es heißt
verschärfte ökonomische sanktionen gegen
russland und putin die finanzen für
diesen krieg zu entziehen
was ist aus dem guten alten frieden
schaffen ohne waffen geworden sie sind
diese kommen doch eigentlich aus der
pazifistischen
ecke ursprünglich einmal oder ich war
nie pazifist und das gewaltfreie der
grünen bei ihrer gründung war auch vor
allem eine selbstverpflichtung also
gewaltfrei zu sein in der politischen
auseinandersetzung das wahrsagen noch
ein echo auf die raf und an den
politischen terrorismus sagen wir wollen
eine zivile politische kultur aber
international hatten die grünen
zumindest immer zwei denkschulen eine
die tatsächlich sagte frieden schaffen
ohne waffen und einige sagte man muss
auch bereit sein gegen massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen gegen
verletzungen des völkerrechts gegen
aggressive mächte mit militärischer
gegengewalt zu antworten zumindest zur
abschreckung er wird sie aufnehmen brief
erscheint ja morgen in der zeit print
online ist ja schon da wie schwer war es
denn mitunterzeichner zu finden gar
nicht schwer
wir hatten etwa einen tag zeit um
unterstützerin für diesen offenen brief
zu finden sind jetzt auf den ersten
schub 57
schriftstellerin
ja wissenschaftler ehemalige politische
größen wie gerhard baum und man spürte
richtig es gab einen bedarf dafür der
boden war reif dafür eine antwort auf
diesen ersten offenen brief von alice
schwarzer und andere die ja sagten
entwaffnet die ukrainisch wir haben
gestern hier genau an diesen tisch
gemerkt wie hoch die emotionen
eigentlich sind zu alice schwarzers
brief eine frau die ihn heute
widersprechen würde es ulrike gewohnt da
waren wir einmal kurz reinschauen was
sie gestern eigentlich dazu gesagt hat
ich glaube tatsächlich dass der brief
eine welle ausgelöst hat und ich stehe
voll umfänglich zu dem brief wie ich
getwittert habe warum weil wenn wir auf
dieses leid gucken von mario pohl den
krankenhäusern butscher und so weiter
dann kann ich nur sagen cicero der
ungerechteste frieden ist
besser als der gerechteste krieg ja und
wenn wir uns jetzt um dieses leid
bemühen diese bilder nicht haben wollen
dann müssen wir frieden machen frieden
machen trieben machen
was hätten sie geantwortet ich würde
sagen liebe ulrike baro das ist richtige
verkehrung der tatsachen
sie macht die angegriffenen
verantwortlich für die opfer ja also die
ukraine die sich selbst verteidigt die
ist dafür das leid der zivilbevölkerung
verantwortlich stadt diejenigen
anzugehen die diesen krieg vom zaun
gebrochen haben gegen ein friedliches
sein nachbarland und der ukraine das
recht auf selbstverteidigung
abzusprechen das empfinde ich als eine
art von zynismus und als nur moralische
bevormundung zu der wir null recht haben
wenn man daran denkt wie der deutsche
nationalsozialismus niedergerungen
werden musste nämlich mit militärischer
gewalt klar ist würdest du zwischen
würdest du vielleicht sogar euro f
bezeichnen das würde ich nicht ich finde
diese debatte unheimlich wichtig weil
sie
laut und deutlich geführt wird und es
ist toll dass es in dem land möglich ist
sich aus zwei diametral
unterschiedlichen perspektiven diese
furchtbaren auseinandersetzung zu nehmen
ich bin von meiner ganzen verankerung
mehr bei sozusagen ihrem brief und ihnen
aber ein gedanke treibt mich dabei immer
um die idee basiert ja darauf zu sagen
wirtschaftssanktionen damit stabilisiert
man russland von innen und ermächtigung
unter tüchtig und der ukraine zur
selbstverteidigung mit waffen ich
verwende jetzt mal eine vokabel ja immer
mehr waffen sozusagen und immer besseren
wagen so glaubt man also kann man putin
in die knie zwingen aber was ist wenn es
nicht klappt also wie ist quasi die
eskalation dieses gedankens noch mehr
waffen noch schärfere sanktionen noch
mehr waffen noch schärfer sein was ist
eigentlich wenn die ukrainische armee in
die knie geht dann soldaten wäre ja die
gleiche logik dann schicken wir soldaten
damit die ukraine sich selber
verteidigen an der an der stelle da bin
ich das verstehe ich rechtlich natürlich
aber ich finde wenn man den gedanken die
mir nahe ist den ich auch unterschreiben
würde weiter denkt kommt man in ein
gewässer in ein fahrwasser wo plötzlich
sich da ein oder andere gedanke der
anderen nicht mehr naiv sondern
vielleicht einfach nur
menschenfreundlich erscheint jetzt wird
weil putin und die russische armee nicht
stärker machen als sie sind ja die
ukraine hat sich im gegen alle
erwartungen erfolgreich verteidigt gegen
den ersten anlauf der russischen armee
kiew eine art blitzkrieg zur u-bahn es
hätte fast niemand sein erwartet und sie
halten auch jetzt obwohl sie viel
schlechter ausgerüstet sind der
russischen offensive im süden und osten
des landes
stand also die ukrainer selbst sind
überzeugt dass sie in der lage sein
werden diesen krieg zu gewinnen wenn sie
die hinreichende unterstützung bekommen
und wir müssen gegenüber russland sehr
klar signalisieren dass wir die ukraine
nicht fallen lassen
aber es ist noch nicht genau die antwort
auf meine sorge also meine sorge ist es
klappt nicht nicht in einem monat im
zweiten teil in telefonaten nicht in
acht monaten in keinem krieg gibt es
eine gewähr ich mein wusste churchill
als er sagte wir werden nicht
kapitulieren
wusste er wie die sache ausgeht oder de
gaulle als er zur résistance aufgerufen
hat gegen die deutsche besatzung in
frankreich
auch die sowjetunion als sie angegriffen
wurde war eigentlich unterlegenen
position also wenn du sie eine
hundertprozentige garantie für einen
militärischen sieg haben wollen dann
kann es gleich lassen dann muss man die
waffen von anfang an strecken aber das
ist eine option die für die ukraine
nicht real ist weil was ist putins ziel
explizit die vernichtung der
eigenständigkeit der ukraine als nation
ja und wenn man gesehen hat was sie in
mariupol angerichtet haben was sie jetzt
mit den zivilisten machen die aus den
belagerten städten kommen sie nämlich
auszusortieren im solche die in russland
in diesem schuljahr verbannung kommen
und solche die dann so ich könnte ja
keine
rassistischen und das ist natürlich die
glauben sie das mit schweren waffen der
krieg laufzeiten zu gewinnen das für die
ukraine das weiß ich nicht also ich
meine das was herr strunz gesagt hat ist
ja richtig sozusagen dann ist die logik
irgendwann vortex und man schickt immer
mehr und mehr und mehr worum es mir geht
ist jetzt wir haben jetzt zwei briefe
also die antwort ist nicht ja oder nein
so für mich persönlich muss ich ganz
ehrlich gestehen emotional sage ich gebt
ihnen alles was sie brauchen aber es
gibt ja noch andere faktoren und mir
geht es ja nicht alleine nur so sondern
ganz deutschland geht so es gibt in
deutschland trend 45 prozent dafür 45
dagegen also wirklich halb halb durch
ist übrigens gesunken im april waren
noch anfang april waren noch 55 prozent
der deutschen wegen dieser losen reden
vom drohenden atomkrieg natürlich aber
die leute haben angst das darf man ja
wohl nachvollziehen
sage ich nicht es gibt situationen in
denen man sich entscheiden muss sind
doch politiker nehmen ja oder nein sagen
muss und dich irgend eine bequeme
position in der mitte von ja aber in der
ukraine ist die frage lassen wir sie
fallen lassen wir zu dass eine großmacht
die auch noch mitglied im sicherheitsrat
der vereinten nationen ist und
eigentlich das völkerrecht waren und
schützen müsste eine andere überfällt um
mir ihren willen aufzuzwingen oder tun
wir alles damit putin diesen krieg nicht
gerinnt das verstehe ich alles das gehe
ich alles mit der der punkt um den es
mehr geht ist ich weiß es ist krieg in
der ukraine und das muss jetzt schnell
gehen aber offensichtlich gibt es den
bedarf in der gesellschaft zu
diskutieren wollen das ja oder nein
sozusagen die friedens machen wir ja
immer beschworen wurde und so jetzt ist
die zeitenwende da wir sind plötzlich
ganz anders wir stellen uns mit anderen
setzen uns mit anderen themen
auseinander und anderen logik das ist ja
für uns deutsche was ganz neues also in
so einer situation waren wir noch nie
jetzt dass wir zum beispiel nummer 1
anna wir haben sagen die
nato-intervention damals in bosnien nach
drei jahren haben wir zugeguckt haben
wir haben kosovo uns beteiligt wir haben
uns in afghanistan beteiligt wir haben
auch auslandseinsätze mal ist jetzt
nicht so aber keine abwägung wo wir
selbst angst haben müssen so zu sagen
was passiert wenn land die konfrontation
eskaliert was hat das für uns deutsche
so also vor den serben vorher musste man
keiner sorge haben in berlin nur mal
ganz kurz bei denen sie zu recht gesagt
dass eine ja oder nein frage also sind
sie auf der seite als sanktionen und
waschen oder auf der neuen seite jahr
hinweg aber mit großen bauchschmerzen
und ich verstehe jeden der sagt ich habe
angst davor frau schwarzer hat angst sie
hat es verklausuliert formuliert
sozusagen der brief ist aber ein jahr
abgesagt sie hatte noch nie in ihrem
leben sei sie geboren ist so viel angst
vor dicht dran bleiben nach motionen
weil wir angst haben opfern über die
ukraine nein ich glaube ernsten bereit
das muss man straßenreinigung im roten
weltkrieg zu den für die opera
kriegspartei zu werden die fragen
sonntags an gegner teil der aus diw sie
sagen sie sagen gerade wurde tags müssen
wir müssen wie die ukraine unterstützen
das heißt auch wie klaus auch vorhin
gesagt hatte in letzter konsequenz heißt
dass die kriegspartei werden und wenn
wir jetzt auch schon die rhetorik der
amerikanischen verteidigungsministers
anhören sagt er ist die ist das ziel
nicht nur die verteidigung der
souveränität von der ukraine sondern er
sagt wir müssen einen punkt kommen dass
russland nie wieder in die lage kommt
ein anderes land zu überfallen das heißt
nicht dass die als offizielle kriegsziel
der weg des westens ist inzwischen nicht
die verteidigung der ukraine nicht mehr
nur sondern auch russland zu schwächen
also da werden wir zur kriegspartei wir
sind längst dabei das zu tun mit den
ökonomischen sanktionen ja die frau
britta heine de rossi dauer war noch wir
wollen dauerhaft aus russischem öl und
gas aussteigen das sind 40 prozent des
staatshaushalts was ist das anderes als
eine politik die sagt wir werden euch
wirtschaftlich finanziell so schwächen
dass er nicht mehr daran ist eine option
getting also der beiden ruft offen zur
zum regime wechsel auf was ich sage nur
also ich bin ehrlichkeit in dieser
ganzen fragen komplett ratlos ich würde
wieder den einen noch den anderen rief
unterscheiden ich bin aber auch sagen
ein familiär ein bisschen traumatisiert
zwar meine urgroßtante die in sarajevo
erschossen wurde und das hätte er hätte
den hätte den meisten menschen europa
endlich egal sein können dass ein
unbeliebter thronfolger und seinen genau
so unbeliebte ehefrau in in sarajevo
erschossen wird aber zehn millionen
junge menschen sind deswegen in denen
ihr kriegs gräben in den schützengräben
gestorben und fast nicht beunruhigt ist
so ein bisschen
diese
der fachbegriff ist polizist muss und
ich finde die über zu übersetzen mit mit
kriegslüsterne als übertrieben aber der
enthusiasmus immer mehr waffen und immer
mehr waffen und jetzt auch noch rust ein
putin stürzen und russland schwächen ich
habe dagegen eine unterirdische rhetorik
wer vertritt hier enthusiasmus wer zieht
mit begeisterung in den krieg niemand
sondern das ist ein auf gezwungener
krieg für die ukraine und für die
europäische union wir müssen uns
entscheiden ob wir akzeptieren dass die
europäische friedensordnung die auf
bestimmten regeln passiert nämlich
gleich souveränität aller staaten keine
gewaltsame veränderung von von grenzen
natürlich menschenrechte hat noch die
alte sowjetunion im helsinki protokoll
akzeptiert als grundlage der
europäischen ordnung ob das alles über
den haufen geworfen wird und zukünftig
das recht des stärkeren herrscht dass
auch eine gefahr für unsere sicherheit
ich ganz ihrer meinung nur und es geht
nicht darum dass wir jetzt die
bundeswehr nach in der ukraine schicken
sondern es geht darum dass wir die
ukraine so stärken dass sie standhalten
kann das wäre jedenfalls möchte mich
noch ein bisschen von dieser ein
bisschen 1914 stimmung wir tun dass er
sie wir sind auf der seite das
leichenteil ist eine angst stimmung in
der republik es ist überhaupt keine
hurra sagen stimmung für wir ziehen in
den krieg sondern es ist eine stimmung
der furcht aber wenn wir uns von furcht
treiben lassen dann machen wir uns
komplett erpressbar sobald putin auch
nur andeutet es gebe die möglichkeit
atomwaffen einzusetzen
geben wir ihm freie hand und das ja
freie zwischen freier hand und
kriegspartei werden ist ja noch ist ja
noch mal einige er heute polarisiert hat
mit seiner haltung ist der papst und das
thema hast du uns mitgemacht klaus
mir war heute lange zeiten des tages
lange phasen des tags danach zu sagen
ein papst zuzurufen mein gott franziskus
weiler hat ein interview gegeben in dem
er tatsächlich ich darüber nachdenkt
dass die nato möglicherweise mit schuld
daran ist dass es zu dieser invasion von
putin in der ukraine kam und er hat
außerdem festgestellt dass er auf jeden
fall zuerst wladimir putin in moskau
besuchen wolle und erst danach
vielleicht nach kiew reist und da habe
ich schon das gefühl den papst ist
womöglich in dieser wichtigen
internationalen krise ein bisschen des
navigationssystem verrutscht weil es ja
nicht nur auf den ersten sondern auch
auf dem zweiten blick so aussieht als
sei ihm die nähe zum täter näher als die
zu den opfern als sei er sozusagen als
politiker er verpflichtet dem aggressor
dem völkermörder das schwert aus der
hand zu schlagen als sich schützend vor
die opfer zu stellen die angegriffenen
dabei wäre das möglicherweise das signal
dass er sein müsste als der große welt
diplomat warum nimmt der papst nicht
einfach jetzt seine sommerresidenz in
odessa oder in mario pohl und beendet
damit dieses furchtbare bombardement das
wäre gelebte nächstenliebe und nicht ein
waghalsiger diplomatischer drahtseilakt
ja es ist natürlich vollkommen
nachvollziehbar und los was du sagen was
du sagst aber würde er jetzt residenz
nehmen in der ukraine wäre das natürlich
eine parteinahme und wenn wir ich finde
erst mal dieses signal dass der papst
sich als vermittler einschalten will
erst mal als ein zeichen der hoffnung
und wenn du ein vermittler ist dann muss
der vermittler zumindest den anschein
erwecken als würde er auch die position
der gegenseite zu verstehen das
vokabular war etwas gewagt also von mir
einer dabei ist es aber quasi fast war
die keinen pressesprecher
sagte er sagte also eher sagte
tatsächlich das bellen also er macht er
sagt eines der faktoren die zu diesen
eskalation geführt haben könnten sei das
bellen der nato vor der tür russlands
das vokabular ist wie gesagt etwas
spielen ist eine falsche worte aber
lassen doch ein schritt zur hessischen
neuer säbel rasseln aber lassen doch ein
schritt zurück sind ist es nicht so dass
aus der sicht des zerfallenden
sowjetunion und später in russland
tatsächlich der westen die nato die eu
recht nahe an die grenzen russlands geht
aber ist nicht die hre hatte uns
verteidigungsbündnis richtig also es ist
so ich will jetzt ich muss immer ich
möchte ich muss wirklich aufpassen nicht
als putin versteher darzustellen aber
ich über stürmerin
werden alexander muss ich weiter reden
besteht
ich erzähl doch lieber eine persönliche
geschichte ist war 1991 ich war an bord
der fregatte rheinland pfalz urteil der
als wehrdienstleistender war an bord der
fregatte rheinland pfalz teil des der
nato mission im standing naval force
atlantic wir haben dort wir sind also
ist ein verband von nato schiffen briten
holländer
deutsche dies gemeinsam in übungen die
in dem in der nordsee und der ostsee
unternommen haben wir waren an einer
einer manöver nördlich von schottland
als die warschauer pakt aufgelöst wurde
1991 an dem tag als der warschauer pakt
aufgelöst wurde wurde diese über das
manöver unterbrochen und wir bekamen
befehl von der nato aus brüssel alle
schiffe sofort im ehemalige häfen der
das war des warschauer paktes an
anlaufen darunter petersburg darunter
italien um dort flagge zu zeigen die
signal war der der des zerfallenen
sowjetunion zu zeigen die nato ist hier
und wir laufen ehemalige ehemalige häfen
an und zwar noch sehr interessant und
wurde damals als wir sind die häfen wie
stockholm an land gingen wurde und
strengstens verboten in uniform an land
zu gehen weil wir wollten natürlich
nicht dass grünen der saufen der nato
soldaten ein schlechtes bild auf die
bundeswehr auf die nato werfen in den
ehemaligen warschauer-pakt-staaten gab's
strikten befehl wenn ihr durch die stadt
geht auch in eurer freizeit trägt
uniform damit jeder sieht dass ihr da
sind und ich musste ich muss sagen ich
habe mir damals schon gedacht ist ich
war ich war immer hardliner ich war
immer franz josef strauß ich war immer
ein kalter krieger ich fand ich fand
auch gesagt kein los ich finde auch
kriegs war auch der der zerfall des
warschauer paktes war für mich als
kalter krieger eigentlich immer ein
triumph für die frage ist also was mit
dem vierer was macht es mit ihm verliert
bis man kann immer gesagt ist es ein
glory es ist eine glorios zu besiegen
aber es ist nicht loriots den gegner zu
demütigen und ich habe mich damals
gefragt ist die demütigung das sagen die
russische machte elite und auch teile
der russischen bevölkerung bis heute
nicht den abschied vom imperium verzogen
haben das kann man ihnen aber nicht
ersparen genauso wenig wie man es
deutschland ersparen konnte wie man ist
frankreich oder großbritannien ersparen
konnte sich von iris material geschickt
es ist sich von ihrem doch das ist auf
obama hatte recht als er
1990 das ist der die charta von paris
die damals noch von gorbatschow
unterschrieben wurde die dann von
russland übernommen wurde selbst die
nato osterweiterung wurde damals von
russland ja gut aus sie ist das
polnische erst die nato russland aktie
nicht gegeben also die einbeziehung
russlands in diesen
sicherheitsmechanismen plane zur kirche
noch mal zurückkommen wir sehen auch
gerade in ihrem hintergrund für welche
rolle spielt er
das ist russische staatskirche in ihrer
imperialen tradition ja das ist das
schulterschluss dann muss man das auch
sagen da hatte die trennung vollzogen
also als war sehr sehr sehr weitreichend
messdiener von booten so dass es schon
also deswegen wundert mich ja dieses
neue ereignis um franziskus so weil da
war vollkommen klar und er hat auch am
anfang dieser invasion sich klar
geäußert und jetzt zieht er sich
offensichtlich mehr in der situation
eines diplomaten und politiker ist als
resultieren zu sprechen sind darum darf
der papst nicht versuchen mit putins hat
sich schon mal sagen das geht damit los
dass der papst sicher sparen sollte dass
er um ein gespräch bittet dass der
andere einfach nicht stattfinden lässt
bringt ja nicht zu vermitteln wenn also
sozusagen alles ist ja das ist ja quasi
eine machtdemonstration bevor
irgendetwas geschehen ist ich bitte dich
um ein abendessen und du sagst mit dir
nicht oder zumindest jetzt nicht das
finde ich könnte sich der
vorsteher und verantwortliche für 1,4
milliarden menschen auf der erde sparen
das zweite ist dass ich glaube dass der
papst als vermittler ich habe immer das
bild im kopf dem aggressor ist sozusagen
das schwert aus der hand risiko dass der
aggressor hier übrigens ein völkermörder
diese bilder benutzen wird für seine
propaganda den papst also quasi ein
spannend guckt mal wir sind gar nicht
sondern wir sind hier auf der größe das
ist wirklich würde mir auch durch den
kopf gehen wenn ich sozusagen wenn der
papst auf mich hören würde was für ein
schöner satz den der papst auf mich an
wird also da finde ich die die rolle von
franziskus wirklich 2 wir müssen unser
ersten mal dankbar sein das ist
hoffnungszeichen gebe es eine solche
friedensmission angeboten werden wir
können doch nicht der logik bleiben
weiter weiter weiter eskalieren wer soll
denn sonst verloren wenn wir in einem
raubüberfall rufen sie da die polizei
oder rufen sie den priestern ja es ist
ja aber wäre es dann nicht sinnvoller
dass sich der papst trifft
ich glaube zwischen den bayern gibt es
nicht viel zu wenn ich glaube ich haben
ja sogar wenn ich das richtig heute
gesehen hat sie haben ja sogar
vereinbart dass sie sich besser nicht
treffen weil sonst die zerrüttung
offenbar wird das schiller ja kann man
glaube ich als sozusagen auf
diplomatischem parkett nicht nicht tun
aber es soll sozusagen
der geistliche führer eines einer so
großen teil eines so großen momenten
menschheit mit einem völkermörder
überhaupt sprechen ist eine interessante
frage es gibt ja leute mit denen man gar
nicht spricht sondern denen man dinge
zeigt das wäre wieder diese das ist ja
auch eine demonstration der stärke
mein gefühl ist dass putin zudem
menschen oder soll ich sagen männer
schlag gehört die auch wirklich nur
signale der stärker verstehen da gibt es
noch einen punkt den ich noch dazu
anmerken möchte also natürlich kann man
versuchen zu vermitteln und dergleichen
aber eigentlich hat man sich als kirche
auf die seite der schwachen und der
armen und entrechteten zu stellen wenn
ich jetzt persönlich dass man so
formulieren darf und ich finde da geht
die katholische kirche jetzt mit dem
papst ganz vorne voran leider macht
jedes schlägt den weg ein wie die
evangelische kirche den auch hat
teilweise hier in deutschland wir haben
ja so einen bull der pazifismus
sozusagen wo dann einfach gesagt wird
ganz egal was hinten raus kommt
hauptsache keine waffen hängt dann auch
ein bisschen zu dem thema davon dass wir
vorher besprochen haben zusammen es gibt
da vielleicht auch nicht so eindeutige
ja nein fragen aber ich finde als papst
und ich finde auch als katholische
kirche und auch als protestantische
kirche als evangelische in dem fall muss
man eigentlich sehr klar an der seite
der ukraine stehen moralisch weil dieses
verhalten als vermittler aus und ich
habe mit den reifen gebe stehe also nach
dem erfolg aber dennoch freue ich mich
über ein der das signal eine
friedensmission wir müssen diese jede
chance jetzt nutzen wir können nicht
einfach in dieser in dieser logik der
eskalation bleiben wir müssen vertrauen
natürlich ist es eben putin sprechen ist
also in dem bild von geraten natürlich
wenn man darauf spekuliert dass der
räuber den priester sagt jetzt wo sie da
sind habe ich mir anders überlegt und
ich gebe gibt es ich gehe nach hause ich
eben die gebäude zurück wenn man darauf
setzt ich würde sagen müssen kinder
vermitteln aber einer muss vermitteln
also es bebt das worauf wir noch hoffen
müssen überdies relation ist wird doch
fand es doch nicht so dass ich
verhandelt würde ja es finden jetzt zwar
keine istanbul finden gestalte ich da ja
und uns online finden also per
video-konferenz die ganze zeit gibt es
konnten gesprächskontakte zwischen der
ukraine und
russland es gibt ja auch nach wie vor
eine westliche diplomatie gegenüber ist
ja nicht so dass nicht gesprochen würde
das problem ist dass da komplett
unterschiedliche ziele und interessen
aufeinanderprallen und solange putin die
hoffnung haben kann dass er durchkommt
mit militärischer gewalt wird er meines
erachtens sich nicht auf einen gerechten
frieden einlassen ein gerechter werden
nur die komplette integrität der denkst
vollkommen unannehmbar dass ein dass
nach lage der dinge so unrealistisch
aber man muss ja als der zurück zum 23
februar zu starten
auswirkungen auch auf deutschland und ja
eine sache herrscht momentan bewegt sie
sehr worauf der staat jetzt mal als
zeichen verzichten könnte ja also
deutschland hat den teuersten öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk der welt und ich
sage mal wir sparen jetzt überall sonst
wir müssen sonst überall opfer bringen
das ding ist zu teuer zu träge und vor
allem auch zu links stefan müller der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der csu
hat deswegen jetzt gefordert mit blick
auf die
galoppierende inflation dass man doch
mal drei monate auf den rundfunkbeitrag
so zu sagen dass man ihn aussetzen
könnte ich sage eigentlich das geht
nicht weit genug wir müssen an den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk mal ganz
grundlegend dran
drei mal pausieren oder er gar nicht
erst finde ich jetzt wie schräg ja man
verfolgt eine agenda den öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk möglich
abzuschaffen und nutzt jetzt die
tatsache dass wir es mit inflation mit
steigenden lebenshaltungskosten zu tun
haben um überlegen sogar noch auto zu
fahren als er schon großes problem ich
bin sehr für entlastung vor allem der
geringeren einkommen es macht einen
unterschied ob nur die eigene sparquote
etwas sinkt oder ob es wirklich ans
eingemachte geht dass man miete oder
lebensmittel kaum noch bezahlen kann
oder das benzin für die pendler da gibt
es aber andere möglichkeiten ja von
einer energie pauschale für selbst in
der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk hat
seine daseinsberechtigung sollte jetzt
auch nicht ja für mich ist das natürlich
rechtliche rundfunk bei aller kritik die
ich auch daran habe das ist eine
institution der demokratie sorry und die
sollte möglichst
staatsfernsehen hier gefällt überhaupt
nicht dass da lauter ministerpräsidenten
und abgeordneten in den rundfunkräten
sitzen sollte möglichst realistisch sein
und sollte auch sparsam sein natürlich
ist der öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk
muss man nicht drumrumreden
sich hypertrophe also der der ist über
seine maßen
immer neue programme immer neue sender
ja das muss nicht sein soll sich
konzentrieren auf seinen informations-
und bildungsauftrag aber dass wir einen
nichtkommerziellen medienbereich haben
das finde ich eine demokratische
errungenschaft darf ich da noch ein
bisschen drauf entgegnen also jetzt den
anlass von stefan müller zu nehmen mit
den preisen das ist einfach eine reale
geschichte wir müssen jetzt einfach mal
bei ganz vielen geschichten überlegen wo
kann man da was kürzen und öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk ist auch eine
institution wo man sparen kann so das
aber jetzt nur als trigger prinzipiell
müssen wir uns schon die frage stellen
wie wollen wir den öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk eigentlich in
zukunft halten weil in seiner jetzigen
form ist ja nicht mehr zeitgemäß das ist
ein konstrukt der frühen 60er jahre wie
er heute da es gibt doppelstrukturen
damit das mal gehört haben neun
landesrundfunkanstalten
74 radiosender je nach zählweise da kann
man sich nicht darauf einigen 12 bis 21
öffentlich rechtliche
fernsehsender alle haben eine eigene
zentralverwaltung leitungspersonal
rechte vermarktung einkauf
aufsichtsgremium et cetera pp herr
sozusagen beim wdr intendant tom buhrow
400.000 jahresgehalt man bayerischen
rundfunk ebenfalls selbst der kleine
saarländische rundfunk hat der intendant
250.000 euro da kann ich doch als ich
jetzt mal ganz im ernst das sind doch
summen da träumt doch jeder normale
private fernsehsender von und das ist
einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß da kann man
wirklich jetzt mal zurückfahren und kann
mal sagen wir kürzen dass auf die hälfte
oder dergleichen wir können auch mal zur
bbc schauen ja die bbc hat in
großbritannien einen etat von 4,8
milliarden der bei uns 9,1 das ist die
hälfte also grob so ich würde nicht
sagen dass die bbc ein schlechteres
nachrichtenangebot liefert als ard und
zdf wenn ich mir die ukraine
berichterstattung anschaue muss ich
sagen tendenziell eine schlechtere die
visier hat natürlich weniger
spartenprogramme und kaka hat ganz eine
ganz andere einnahmequellen weil sie die
die politischen programme lassen sich
auf der ganzen welt verkaufen sie können
jetzt sie können jetzt den den also bis
auf derrick oder was kann man sehr wenig
von den tag oder kann man sehr wenig was
in deutschland produzierte international
verkaufen babys sie ist natürlich auch
ein riesiges event center wörter sind
produzieren als auch der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk hat ja auch
schadstoffe verkauft jetzt aus latsch
ist es ja nicht ich habe mir anderen maß
als in alt als ein sender wir auf der
ganzen welt schon wieder sprache
verkaufen verstehst du denn das vorhaben
alexander oder die idee wenn man sie 236
super ich würde jetzt mal annehmen dass
es hier möglich ist am tisch zu tanzen
aber für viele menschen bestimmt auch
verdient denn dann können auch gedanken
aber für viele menschen ist es ja
wirklich dass sie über autofahrten auch
nachdenken wie würdest du das denn
einschätzen das vorhaben weil drei
monate zu pausieren und vielleicht auch
als öffentlich rechtlicher rundfunk ein
zeichen zu setzen ich glaube das ist ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein gemacht wie
macht die preissteigerung enormen die
sorge ich glaube dass die inflation im
moment ist wirklich ist höchst
gefährdend für für niedrige und mittlere
einkommen wir steuern auf eine auf eine
nationale
wirtschaftspolitik weiter
alterssicherung ist wenn
die leute die etwa kleine
gewerbetreibende älterwerden zu geschäft
denn sie hatten keine rentenversicherung
die waren darauf angewiesen zu sparen
und rücklagen für das alter zu bilden
und die werden gerade massiv entwertet
ich habe ja mal ein buch geschrieben die
kunst des stilvollen verarmen und habe
dabei entweder vorausgesagt dass wir
alle ärmer werden das sieht dass sich
das sich tatsächlich meine prophezeiung
von den weg jetzt war er weiß hätte ich
nicht gedacht es ist tatsächlich so dass
wir auf eine dass wir alle
wahrscheinlich in zukunft auf die zeiten
der 80er 90er nullerjahre als
paradiesisch zurückschauen wir werden
uns alle sehr viel mehr einschränken das
liegt aber auch daran dass wir viele
kosten wie die ökonomen sagen
ausgelagert haben externalisierung ich
habe einmal kosten ausgelagert und wir
haben sicherheitskosten ausgelagert
jetzt müssen wir den preis dafür
bezahlen
ich finde ich finde das letzte sagte
echt wichtig obwohl sie an die laune
verdirbt das mache ich jetzt mal ganz
kurz ich sehe dieses kann die ganze
preis debatten die wir jetzt führen die
lebenshaltungskosten alles möglich ist
natürlich das pendel weit ausgeschlagen
in die richtung aber die richtung bleibt
also im glauben das leben wird so wie
wir es leben wollen ich sage auch noch
dazu wir sind an gespritzt so wie wir
das leben sollen politisch gewollt
teurer werden und das kann ja gruber
grund seien weil sie uns dann länger gut
geht auf dieser welt aber die menschen
den menschen klarzumachen dass es so wie
in den nuller jahren nicht mehr werden
wird das finde ich auch eine wichtige
funktion der politik insofern finde ich
schon richtig drauf zu gucken wo man
vielleicht geld her holen kann
aber nicht darüber hinwegzutäuschen dass
unser leben in der zukunft aufgrund der
film vielen dinge die wir geschrieben
haben teurer werden wird allein ich
meine jeder ihre eltern im schuhgeschäft
hätten doch nicht lage rechnen müssen
nach wie viele milliarden bei corona
nach soviel milliarden für den krieg in
dessen ende nicht absehbar ist nach
sowieso einer staatsverschuldung und
nach dem ausbau auf eine völlig neue
energieformen und dann kommt er jetzt
kein schuhverkäufer auf die idee dass
alles so bleibt wie jetzt sondern da
kommen große dinge auf uns zu und ich
sag jetzt mal ein bisschen
despektierlich ihr politiker tut gut
daran wenn er die menschen früh genug
damit nimmt ihn auf dieser reise
wenn sie zustimmen hertha spielt die
fans auch für unsere diskussion von über
den ukraine krieg der bundeskanzler hat
eigentlich nach seiner berühmten
zeitenwende rede dann wieder
zurückgerudert und versucht die leute zu
berühren die eigentlich gar nicht halten
wollte die zeit zu beruhigen wollte
eigentlich gar nicht brauchen so wir
halten diesen krieg von euch weg und das
ist kein politischer finden ich habe
noch eine frage freuen sich denn
eigentlich die grünen jetzt über die
steigenden spritpreise war eigentlich
wollten die grünen ja auch das bedeutet
es werden also immer wichtig zu wissen
also was die grünen ich bin ja kein
parteisprecher und auch nicht mehr aktiv
und habe dann aber mitglied wegen der
ökologischen frage und das stimmt schon
dass die grünen sagen wir sollen hier
sich den sprit subventionieren weil das
ist gut wenn der teurer wird dann wird
weniger gefahren oder man steigt um auf
öffentliche verkehrsmittel da wo das
möglich ist sondern wir sollten niedrige
einkommen entlasten indem man den eine
energie pauschale zahlt damit sie ihre
energiekosten sagen decken können aber
nicht am preis rummachen der preis hat
in der marktwirtschaft eine wichtige
steuerungsfunktion
versprechen noch eine forderung ich habe
jetzt aber dass in st also hat sagt
mission der competition vorherzusagen
euro gleich dem mehr
so konsequent wie lang eine ganz kurze
unterbrechungen sind gleich wieder
zurück bei ihnen und dann geht es hier
um die einrichtungs beziehungen pflicht
bis gleich bleiben sie dran wir sind
zurück schön dass sie dran geblieben
sind und ich möchte jetzt über einen wir
sind sprechen der mich seit monaten
aufregt seit der einführung und wir
bekommen aber als film nach redaktion
ganz viele nachrichten darüber und ich
finde es sehr wichtig dass wir darüber
heute sprechen werden und das ist die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht bei
diesen ihr sind sprechen wir jetzt finde
es wirklich eine frechheit das muss ich
wirklich sagen wir hatten am montag und
das freut mich da gab es keinen kroner
toten binnen 24 stunden eine großartige
nachricht aber darauf musste politik
doch jetzt endlich reagieren wie kann es
denn sein dass wir immer noch die
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht haben
wie kann es sein dass pfleger wenn sie
nicht geimpft sind daran verzweifeln und
nur darauf warten wann werden sie jetzt
eingezogen also wann wird das
gesundheitsamt wann werden sie dorthin
gemeldet und dann dürfen sie nicht mehr
arbeiten ich finde das muss aufhören und
ich möchte es wirklich noch mal ganz
klar machen ist kann nicht wahr sein
dass ich beispielsweise als journalistin
nicht überprüft werde aber dass
pflegekräfte also die menschen die wir
so sehr brauchen die in der kroner krise
härter gearbeitet haben als ich als
journalist dass die jetzt weiterhin eine
impfpflicht haben ich finde es eine
bodenlose frechheit der politik und
deswegen finde ich dass es aufhören muss
doch als letzten punkt möchte ich
ergänzen die politik macht übrigens mit
der einrichtungs beziehungen im pflicht
nicht nur die pflege kaputt oder noch
härter als ich schon ist sondern sie
drängt die pflegekräfte in die
querdenker und auch das muss endlich
aufhören weil die ems entscheidung ist
eine persönliche entscheidung die jeder
für sich alleine treffen muss und auf
darf jetzt bin ich gespannt wie die
runde darüber denkt und ich gebe direkt
mal an sie herr fuchs
zustimmen werden das gefühl trügt sie
nicht weil es gibt schon eine besondere
verantwortung von pflegekräften gilt
auch für gesundheitspersonal in
krankenhäusern nämlich für ihre
schutzbefohlenen für die patienten für
die alten in der pflegestation und wir
hatten zum teil extreme
infektionsquellen in pflegeheimen in
altenheimen und deshalb ist das eher
doppelter schutz für
die menschen die dort versorgt werden
aber auch für das pflegepersonal ja und
wenn pflegepersonal reihenweise ausfällt
weil sie sich gegenseitig anstecken dann
trägt das auch mutter wenn sie
reihenweise ausnahmsweise nicht geimpft
sind noch nicht mehr dürfen ja ich meine
es gibt ja in vielen dann frankreich zum
beispiel sagen diese impfpflicht seien
im
gesundheitssystem klopp die haben sogar
auf die
bildungseinrichtung sagen mit mit
übertragen der große frage mich an ich
frage mich immer also warum
verweigern dass die leute ja ist das
eine frage von aufklärungen von beratung
aber was kann man tun um sie zu
überzeugen aber zunächst ist das nicht
bevormunden sondern es ist
ja und in solchen einrichtungen in denen
der infektionsgefahr besonders große ist
habe ich auch verständnis für
nicht was es mit den nebenwirkungen ich
habe meine zeit mitgebracht und zwar
gibt es also das paul-ehrlich-institut
0,2 prozent entschieden an durch die
krone impfung aber laut einer impfstudie
von professor dr harald mathis geht man
von 0,8 prozent aus von der charité und
das sind bei rund 179 millionen
impfdosen sind das ca 1,5 millionen
schwere nebenwirkung schwere zeit wäre
das heißt impfschäden schwere
nebenwirkung hassenstein wirkung das da
ist können dauerhafte sein zb häufig ist
das vorhandensein zu viele
autoantikörper blutplasma dem betroffen
machen sie jetzt aber gerade gegen das
impfen ich mache keine propaganda
dagegen lassen sie mich ausreden ich
würde aber auch keine dafür machen weil
ich bin weder eine die dafür jetzt
werden will oder nicht ist es für jeden
eine medizinische entscheidung nur ärzte
können dafür werben oder dagegen was
sagen aber ich weiß nicht ich bin ja
keine ärztin aber was ich eigentlich
sagen weil es bei dieser einrichtung
bezogenen impfpflicht
dürfen wir es den menschen aufzeigen
wenn es nebenwirkungen gibt und es gibt
ja im stehen in deutschland auch von der
krone ja weil ich meine jungs schäden
sind doch auch statistisch viel geringer
absolut die zeit die schäden durch
corona und zwar gerade bei hochaltrigen
leuten und bei kranken menschen also mit
denen wir es zu tun haben in
pflegeheimen und in krankenhäusern da
kann man doch nicht drum herum reden ist
eine abwägung von risiken niemand sagt
ich meine ich bin kein mediziner würden
keine biologe aber niemand sagt impfen
ist vollkommen harmlos und risikofrei es
geht um eine abwägung zwischen möglicher
schäden durch impfen unter schäden durch
nicht impfen
aber wir reden jetzt von jungen oder
oder ich sag's mal 130 in pflege
liga unter 3 na ja aber ich sage es
zumindest nicht im rentenalter so und
dass die frage kann man sich schon
stellen ich persönlich bin bei dem thema
ein bisschen zwiegespalten im trevi denn
ja es ist immer alles jahr nein man muss
auch ein bisschen irgendwo in der mitte
prinzipiell bin ich gegen die
impfpflicht prinzipiell bin ich auch
eher gegen einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht ich verstehe die argumente
aber und das ist mir wichtig es ist
nicht immer jeder irgendwie fundamental
opposition der sagt ich möchte mich
nicht impfen lassen und es gibt auch
leute die irgendwie durch impfschäden in
der familie in der vergangenheit oder
dergleichen irgend wie vor geprägt sind
und manche leute auch da haben wir das
thema wie bei frau schwarzer sind
einfach ängstlicher und wollen gewisse
risiken nicht eingehen jetzt muss man
abwägen ist mir die korona infektion ist
die für mich kritischer oder ist das
impfschaden risiko für mich höher ich
kann persönlich sagen ich bin mit corona
erkrankt gewesen für mich ist es eine
laufende nase gewesen und das war es
dann aber auch drei mal geimpft weiß
nicht wie sonst ausgefallen sie habe
nach dem booster so auch wir werden ja
alles noch hundertmal
geburtstag
außenminister sagen es ist da eben auch
nicht wenn man gegen einen einjährigen
der natürlich heikel lebendig gespann
wäre wenn sozusagen glaubensbekenntnisse
ausgetauscht moralische kriterien
angewendet dann finde ich das ganz toll
und eine debatte und dann können sie
hier das war ich würde mal einen
wettbewerbsgedanken ins rennen werfen
ich glaube wenn der tag kommt an dem die
einrichtungen und die es da geht keine
pflege mehr haben weil so viele sagen
wenn es dann impfpflicht gibt dann ist
das kein arbeitsplatz für mich ist sie
so schnell weg die impfpflicht wie wir
gar nicht sozusagen schauen können das
heißt ich plädiere dafür selbst diese
hoch moralische hoch heikle und mit
guten gründen beim diskutierte frage den
markt entscheiden zu lassen das wird das
regulativ sein denn dann ist ihr
argument der abwägung noch mal anders
dann würde ich sozusagen als staaten
überlegen ist jetzt nicht die abwägung
möglichst viele pfleger zu haben um für
die menschen in not da zu sein und ist
dann nicht das gericht in der abwägung
die impfpflicht redaktion ihren haben
sie das schon mal gefragt welche
pflegekräfte gekündigt haben oder wie
viele krankenschwestern weil ihnen das
infektionsrisiko zu haben oder weil die
arbeitsbedingungen so miserabel sind und
die bezahlung wichtiges thema den
arbeits gegeben dass das stimmt ist
vermischt sich natürlich aber ich glaube
dass er sozusagen
das kennzeichen für den arbeitsplatz du
musst geimpft sein sonst kannst du hier
nicht arbeiten wird auch im wettbewerb
unter druck kommt und dann ist die
debatte ganz neu aber nach den gleichen
prinzipien das wäre mir wichtig auch
dann nach einer abwägung was jetzt das
sinnvolleres ich habe das gefühl dann
kann man auch zu der auffassung gelangen
sind voller kunst leben einrichtungs
bezogen wieder wegzunehmen also ich
würde gerne über mein thema reden wenn
ich mir wenig da war aber ich hab mich
schon da drüber über mike wiemann
interessanter ist
[Gelächter]
eine tolle sache dass du nach wie vor
temperatur als bei diesem thema ich
möchte dieses thema zu behalten möchte
das wort krone hat mindestens bis zum
herzlich mal hören und zwar jetzt bin
ich wahnsinnig verein druckt dass du
diesen zungenbrecher einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht unfallfrei
aussprechen kann sondern vielleicht noch
ein baut und dann kommt nicht mehr dran
ja kein einziges wort und dann in extra
in ein selbst entwickeltes nur noch zwei
sätze dazu sage ich glaube die pflicht
sowohl die einrichtungs bezogene als
auch die allgemeine werden durch die
durchseuchung die wir gerade erleben
irgendwann hinfällig werden also dadurch
dass wir es dann alle irgendwann hatten
ist dann die geschichte auch hoffentlich
vorbei und das braucht gar keine
ernstlichen gegeben sie sind können auf
einen milderen verlauf nachdem ich jetzt
mehr gelangweilt habe also ich hoffe sie
nicht da draußen die
brasilianische so und insoweit löchern
es geht los geht und warum ist becker
ich bin heute in die sendung kommen ich
will sie ja das ist gleich dazu da dazu
auch einen selbstkritischen satz ich bin
heute die sendung gekommen um mit ihnen
mein mitgefühl mit boris becker zu
teilen für mich ist boris becker
deutsches kulturgut und mit kulturgut
geht man pfleglich um ich finde wir
haben die verdammte oder besser gesagt
die heilige pflicht wo bis vor den
folgen seines ruhmes in schutz zu nehmen
dieses ganze land hat kollektiv von
boris becker besitz ergriffen als er mit
17 diesen historischen wimbledon-sieger
errungen hat er wurde zu unser aller
adoptivsohn und jetzt haben wir eine
fürsorgepflicht für diesen adoptiv und
wir haben dadurch dass wir ihn so
hochgejubelt haben alle dazu beigetragen
dass er als junger star den bezug zur
realität verloren hat und dadurch
verbietet sich jetzt jede häme ich
fordere solidarität am liebsten wäre mir
ein auslieferungsgesuch an
großbritannien boris hat es nicht
verdient zweieinhalb jahren diesen
abscheulichen mittelalterlichen knast in
londons world zu schmachten er soll an
uns überstellt werden damit der 200
jahre auf staatskosten in einem
deutschen fünf-sterne-hotel eingesperrt
im adlon gerne er kann ja auch eine
fußfessel bekommen und jetzt jetzt jetzt
zu dem was über sie gesagt knast ich
habe mich an dem tag ich bin ich bin ein
treuer loyaler redakteur der bild
zeitung ja ich habe mich an diesem
morgen richtig geärgert über unsere
schlagzeile spiel satz knast ich fange
das war das war heimisch und hat mich
dann gefreut dann aber seit zwei den den
empathischen kommentar von franz wagner
zu lesen der ihn seit er 17 jahre alt
ist kennt ich finde überhaupt unser
umgang mit unseren helden etwas
befremdlich finde mir ging das mit uli
hoeneß auch schon so jetzt weiß ich dass
uli hoeneß wenn eine person die figur
ist er spaltet mir ging das bei franz
beckenbauer so ich fahren darunter
umgang mit franz beckenbauer auch nicht
okay mir ging es mit jan ullrich ähnlich
ich finde und ich frage mich manchmal
woran das liegt ich glaube langsam mehr
verdacht dass wir darauf dass wir dazu
neigen zu vergessen dass auch stars
menschen sind und man muss daran dieses
dieser knast im wandsworth muss nicht
mehr vorstellen der ist unterirdisch
kein deutsches gefängnis
würde solche zustände gedulden da würden
das ist unwahr diese gefängnisse in
england zum 20 19 jahrhundert wer hat
eine kloschüssel im raum und da kann er
nicht einmal ein vorhang zuziehen ich
finde es unmöglich und die deutschen so
viel luxus wer für luxuriöser und ich
heute noch mal und noch mal kurz zu
einem organischen was würde er
hat auch etwas in dem besser ein zu
seinen delikten gehörte
interessanterweise etwas hoch anständige
werde mich versucht seiner mutter das
haus zu bewahren das als eines der
vermögenswerte die auf deckt hat war
dieses haus in leimen wo seine mutter
drin wohnt das hat eher versteckt weil
er sehr vielleicht auch niemals sein
dürfen aber ich möchte trotzdem daran
erinnern wie gesagt dass das motiv
seinem seiner mutter an seiner alten
mutter das hat dass das davor davor zu
bewahren dass ihr haus verliert und
irgendwie als alte dame plötzlich auf
der straße landet ist jetzt erstmal
etwas das das spricht für mildernde
umstände nach meinen nach meinem
dafürhalten also ich finde mich stört
und ich habe hohen respekt vor rosberg
und ich muss sagen unsere leser haben
ein sehr sehr gutes gespür wir haben ja
heute in der bild eine ganze seite
gemacht mit dem mit leserbriefen und ich
muss sagen ich bin begeistert von
unseren lesern nicht immer von unserer
eigenen redaktionellen leistungen mit
dieser schlagzeile den eigenen leuten
und dann geht er aber in diskussion über
boris das riecht sagt rainer buckel aus
neufahrn in bayern libor ist das
wichtigste nach einer niederlage egal ob
beim poker tennis oder im leben ist es
wieder aufzustehen weiter zu kämpfen und
ein sein comeback zu glauben viel kraft
dafür du schaffst das das ist das ist
finde ich man sieht dass unsere leser
ein ganz gesundes gespür haben habe ich
ein bisschen
erstmal finde ich es toll dass man sich
über die schlagzeile auch ärgern kann
ich habe mich über die schlagzeile
gefreut weil sie nämlich was genial
isches tut ich habe die gar nicht als
empfunden sondern sie ersetzt ja das
wort sieg durch das wort knast und das
sind die beiden pole in der karriere von
boris becker also nach gerade in dieser
geniale
das heißt du warst in der konferenz
sind diese kenianischen zeile sind ist
quasi boris becker ins leben er einmal
in seiner ganzen tragik in seiner ganzen
höhe und tiefe gefasst wer es aber
sozusagen fast nur nur in klammern ich
bin natürlich gegen häme aber ich bin
schon dafür dass straftäter ihrer
gerechten strafe zugeführt werden müssen
und deshalb sind auch die beispiele der
beispiele die duh genannt hast den von
prominenten und im umgang mit
prominenten nicht ganz wirklich eine
reihe also uli hoeneß straftäter boris
becker straftäter bei jan ullrich
erinnere ich mich an keine straftat ist
sozusagen er in morales in menschliche
wir kommen klar hat er hat betrogen beim
radfahren aber dass das ist irgendwie
was anderes ich glaube dass also ich
liebe dein impuls und dass wir uns immer
fragen müssen wie gehen wir mit diesen
instanzen mit dem kulturgut um ich finde
aber bei dem kleinen und strafe beim
strafrecht ist eine grenze und jetzt
kommt der punkt in ich fühle dabei ich
finde ich sehe ihn auch nicht
gerechterweise in diesem gefängnis also
weil ich sehen auch übrigens nicht in
dem fünf sterne hotel sondern es ist ich
sehe auch nicht mit fußfesseln was
diskutiert worden ist warum also das
strafmaß ist nur zweieinhalb jahre und
da wird er 15 monate davon dem gefängnis
sein und dann kann man mal nachdenken
warum er so pummelig so dusselig so
deutlich oder so vorsätzlich war wie das
gericht ihm sozusagen nachgewiesen hat
dass
da ist eine grenze und die die zu
verbessern durch zu viel ich habe ja so
eine leichte ironische zuspitzung schon
erkannt in deiner in seiner these aber
die zu verwässern an der stelle mit zu
viel kult und damit auch eine straftat
zu relativieren finde ich schwierig dass
jemand zweieinhalb jahre kriegt weil er
im großen stil muss man zugeben aber ein
ein geld delikt begangen hat und wir
manchmal menschen das sehen die anderen
menschen körperlich was antun die nicht
zweieinhalb jahre ins gefängnis müssen
das stört mich ist aber leider ein alter
ein alter gegenstand in der
auseinandersetzung mit mit dem
rechtssystem das
vergehen oder taten gegen das eigentum
in der tendenz brutaler bestraft werden
als
körperverletzung das stört mich daran
ihr jetzt er öffentlich meine die
diskussion aber entwicklung etwas
kürzere antworten so schaffen wir heute
nicht mehr alle ich bin mir sicher ist
und dann auch sie herr petzner mal tage
ist boris becker nun ein held oder ein
verbrecher sitzt er zu recht im knast
wie sind ihre empfindungen
ich würde sagen ist ein gefallener held
also ich teile völlig sein ihre
wut an ihre emotionen gegen diese ham ja
also das dass man dann noch emotional
nachtritt und der ist die gleichen die
ihn vorher in den himmel geschossen
haben jetzt sich über in eifern
verdammen so das ist mir alles viel zu
viel überschuss aber ich glaube es gibt
einen punkt
den sie gemacht haben
herr strunz man kann ihn nicht aus
seiner verantwortung entlassen
ja und er ist für sein leben und für
sein handeln verantwortlich wie jeder
andere bürger und bürgerinnen auch und
die tatsache dass er ein nationaler
harris war dass die die nation zu füßen
lag und der genannte mystery
war kann ihnen davon nicht entlasten
ob jetzt die steuern ich habe diesen
prozess verfolgt ich bin jetzt zufällig
in dieser runde hier gerade die
straße
oder andere das kann ich gar nicht sagen
beurteilen aber ich glaube dass er eben
auch zu den besten auch wieder ullrich
gehört die mit weder dem ruhm noch dem
reichtum wirklich sagen auch wenn ja
dann kommen der einmal nach einem
verschneider montag ich muss nur kurz
einfach denn es gibt ja viele stars und
jetzt mal die häme auszuweiten ja das
beispiel die sängerin nena die wird ja
auch mit häme überschüttet ihre songs
dürfen nicht mehr oder weil vielen
radiostation nicht mehr laufen wie sehen
sie das denn insgesamt im umgang mit
prominenten in deutschland ob wir
heimisch sind ja wir sind ja auch
leitkultur volk also durch und durch
also das ist leider eine der negativen
eigenschaften der deutschen man gönnt
anderen den erfolg nicht das ist ich bin
öfter im jahr in los angeles mein mann
lebt dort und da geht man ganz anders
mit um das ist auch sehr protzig und
sehr neureich europäisch verhältnisse
aber mir ist das sympathischer wenn
leute erfolg haben den usa auch sehr oft
selfmade gerade in los angeles wo man
sich neu erfindet wenn man dahin zieht
und uns selbst was erreicht warum sollen
wir es nicht zeigen ich möchte nicht in
einem weißen rolls royce mit roten
ledersitzen durch die gegend fahren aber
wenn man das möchte dann soll man das
tun
die deutschen sind da wahrscheinlich
besonders hämisch wobei ich sagen muss
also bei boris becker so hart und so
böse wie die britische yellow press
sozusagen mit ihren eigenen stars umgeht
da hatte boris becker bei uns noch gut
getroffen da ist nur das sentiment der
leute irgendwie ein bisschen anders aber
gutes abschließendes statement wir sind
nämlich schon am ende der sendung
unterscheiden sie morgen haben doch
wieder ein bisschen abend noch bis bald
[Musik]